finally tonight a quick word on the
census you may remember that we covered
it on the show last year when we learned
that donald trump thought it was when
you count how many toilets are in
people's houses which you know
it isn't the census is how the
government determines things like the
number of seats each state has in the
house and the distribution of federal
funds and given everything that we just
talked about earlier in the show
concerning underrepresentation
it could not be more important for
people to fill it in unfortunately with
the pandemic has become
a bit of a with the latest
news coming just this week
all right breaking overnight a federal
court ordering the trump administration
to drop
plans to rush the census to a conclusion
and extending
counting in the census for an additional
month now the census results determine
future congressional
districting and how federal funding is
divvied up across the country
commerce secretary wilbur ross had
ordered the census bureau to finish
counting by september 30th one month
earlier than originally planned
the ruling is expected to be appealed
yeah the deadline for the census was
initially july 31st
then it was pushed back to october 31st
then pointlessly moved forward
to september 30th which is in just three
days and now
the courts will decide whether that's
actually the deadline or not but
regardless of when the deadline is
it is soon and currently estimates are
that around 14 million households
haven't participated basically the
census is something everyone should do
but some of us aren't putting in the
same category
as flossing except instead of getting
gingivitis you're getting
underrepresented in congress
and if you are one of those people who
hasn't filled it out yet i cannot
overstate how important it is
that you do so and it's so easy just go
to this website or
if you love phone calls for some reason
dial this number the census bureau says
that you'll be done in less than 10
minutes but honestly and not to brag
i found it took me less than two so why
not do it
right now because you definitely have
two minutes on your hands and the reason
i know that for sure is we are currently
28 minutes
into a 30-minute show and i'm about to
drive you away
to go fill it in and if you're thinking
well i don't know about that
i'm pretty comfortable right now not for
long you're not
because for the rest of this show i'm
going to leave you watching this
screensaver
of a dvd logo bouncing around like a
substitute teacher who fell asleep after
glory ended and
not only that underneath it we're going
to be playing the audiobook version of
sean penn's
bob honey who just do stuff read by its
author
a man with a face that's seen better
days and a voice that's seen better
centuries
the book has no formal plot a president
character referred to only as
mr landlord and it contains lines like
effervescence lived
in her every cellular expression and she
had spitzerington to spare
it is dreadful so please save yourself
and go to my2020census.gov right now and
if you've already filled out your census
why not use the time to register to vote
you can find information
on how to do that right here and if
you've already done both of those things
run from this screen like the wind thank
you so much for watching that is our
show we'll see you next week
take it away bob the america bob drove
from woodview to new orleans
was not that one of lore not the one
he'd known in his earliest
cross-continental automotive excursions
not the one of pay later gas stations
vintage diners and two-lane roads
only the trains remained a spirit refuge
to modernity's craven trumpery
there were few remaining romantic vistas
experienced in solitude
but rather interstates strip malls
retail emporiums
traffic road work and bottlenecks
america it seemed to bob was no longer
that beautiful girl who birthed him but
instead
the ghost of a girl he'd never known
driving at night through the
intermittent expanses could bob
sometimes see
the distant amber lights of isolated
compounds
perhaps prisons perhaps casinos
in either case somebody was in there
losing
it seemed many of the towns were built
either on the back of votex
or on the job security offered by
various states corrections departments
at one diner stop in san antonio bob sat
at a counter where he was drawn into
conversation by a grinning
septuagenarian traveler from appalachia
bob impulsively asked what's with all
the incest in your area
he watched the old man's grin go grim
then the old man looked to bob with
defiance
he stepped up and answered bob's
question quietly
just folks getting by and so it was
you